qui va là où vraiment c'est moche
présentez-vous way au c'est comme ça que
son beau frère oncle wade à la famille
tu vas rester avec nous que wade c'est à
ton père d'en décider c'est d'or dans ma
chambre tu es ici chez toi
depuis combien de temps on est ma classe
qui vous volent depuis que maman sont
étalés à cheval rôle gasqueton frère à
mener pour nous attend est ton père te
papa dit qu'ils sont désespérés qu'on
les touche
je sais c'est pas du sublime bien sûr
les macaques qui ont quelque chose à
voir là dedans pas vrai un homme doit
faire très attention à ne pas se mêler
trop d affaires des autres
ouais je n'aurais pas mieux dit mohamed
hilare des ti en train de les voler
parce que tu lui avait dit de le faire
tu t'attendais à quoi
randolph on à rembourser notre dette
c'est moi qui décide quand la dette en
conseil et ses droits demain la veille
mon beau frère qui lui pris pour qui les
problèmes disparaissent des doués pour
s'annoncer mousse c'est vrai ce que tu
as dit qu'un vrai homme doit défendre sa
famille
mais aussi ce prix
de savoir comment c'était la guerre tu
crois ça tu sais quand j'avais à peu
près tournage pour père m'a demandé ce
que je ferais si je trouvais sur un loup
est-ce que je paniquerait je mens furet
et dieu dit une fois leur à point et toi
tu laisses les abc faisait voler plus de
ma nièce est ce que j'essaierai de
l'effrayer c'est lui qui t'a fait ça à
vous
ouais c'est vrai comme si je ne l'avais
même pas vu culture et même s'il n'avait
pas l'intention de me faire du mal
il aurait pu
me reste une balle je t'attendais tu
sais